come on big guy let's get it going again get it
moving let's go here we go move I'm already
breathing hard boys go go go get him let's
go black come on now right here get
up juice yeah baby wake up let's go
we got to take that next step we got to
take this year yeah we're not done yeah
yeah yes you guys had three lines shut up let's
go to work fellas start the climb start the
climb it's nearly 8,000 M across the Pacific
from Melbourne Australia to Los Angeles and
upon returning from their preseason Excursion
Down Under the California coast had to feel
comforting to the LA Kings and yet the schedule
offers little time for relaxation less than two
weeks remain before the start of the regular
season and head coach Todd mclen has little
interest in easing back into work let's get going
today you got jobs to do y ready go go go move it
move it move it next line ready the ability to
get through the Australia trip as far as the
fatigue the travel potential injury was satisfying
good they're figuring a few things out concerns
have been the time off since we've got back not
playing any games with our regulars perhaps the
lack of practice time because of the Australian
trip a bit of a concern there are we behind and
the ability to evaluate hasn't existed now we're
into that Final Phase is back in North America
looking to finalize the roster I guess first
thing we'll start putting together rosters for
Tuesday Thursday Saturday Sunday's a day off for
the whole club Monday we'll have to start getting
down probably I'd like to get you down to five
lines if we're healthy then our decision will be
whether we go 13 forwards 60 12 forwards 70 y you
only have one extra player yep let's say we went
12 forward 70 we have an injur that D plays yeah
so you go we have one more then we're in emergency
situation we can pick what position and weall and
I'll give you a list of the players eligible but
just maybe when you're taunting your staff this
week just start thinking is an extra forward more
important than an extra D yeah still the three
goalies yeah I think we'll Carry Three all week
sure probably for the first time heading
into a season there is some cloudiness of
who the number one guy is been looking for
individuals Phoenix cop play being one of
them obviously cam tbot David Ridge
they're all coming in to compete for
ice time and for job what that does is it
puts everybody on notice and it keeps them
competitive and somebody will grab the games and
and run with it and that's what we're looking for
[Music] among the three candidates in King's camp
bidding for the starting net minder job David
ridit has made a strong impression after signing
with LA in hopes he could stick I want to play NHL
that's uh that's still my dream and it was when
I was a kid and it's still it's still my dream
so see what's going to happen the 31-year-old
Czech is competing in Camp with a pair of fellow
veterans just as hungry and each carrying their
own distinctive story I always believed in what
I could do at the NHL level I just wanted to find
the the opportunity and you know where I was at
before it wasn't happening and so you know as a
free agent I came here and just went to work and
tried to carve out a rooll for myself I just
tried to make the most of that chance Phoenix
Copley is in his 10th season as a pro but before
last year he played Just 31 NHL games he was the
king's Third String Goalie when his number was
unexpectedly called at mid-season Phoenix came
in at a real crucial time in our season last year
where where the stability in that position was
needed and he stepped up and he gave us that compl
with the left leg kept it out and the Kings win it
and come back fashion last year I came in and did
what I had to do and now I got a new opportunity
this year to uh to earn a spot and and show what
else I can do at this level so that's my goal and
uh that's what I'm working on come on there you
go boy cover great job I like it I like it that
was so good depth was perfect like you looked
really comfortable there decisive right I mean
didn't know much about him coming in obviously I
knew that from what I was told that he is a lot
like me we took a lot of the same paths kind of
journey man took a while to get into the league
and we both want to battle we both want the net so
um it's going to be a good healthy competition and
uh that's all I can really ask for cam talet is
36 the kings are his seventh career NHL team and
he's been pushing Copley and ridit in the battle
for the starting job I save that one off my head
oh yeah nice the 2022 Allstar says he chose Los
Angeles for the chance to make an immediate impact
on a title Contender uh I mean first and foremost
at this point in my career I want to win and this
is a team that's you know at that stage and and
they're ready to to take that next step now and
win a championship again so um that was a big
factor in my decision and then again uh competing
for starts head up I'm getting up there in goal
years I guess you can say but I still have the
fire the drive and obviously I would I would love
to start opening night there's nothing like it
especially at home I'd love to be the first one
out of that tunnel I'm a very competitive guy I
wasn't just ready to to give that part up yet so
to compete for starts was huge and then lastly
probably uh just playing for Todd again I played
for him for four years in Edington I had some of
my best seasons under him I know what I'm going to
get with him and he knows what he's going to get
for me so uh it was a great relationship there
and I'm looking forward to building that again
boy T we are three goalies here kind of battling
for for two jobs and I think that competition is
great it's it's been it's been good so far and uh
you know we'll see what's going to happen no goal
no goal we want to push each other I boy copper
cuz at the end of the day when we push each other
we make the team better so that's that's what
we're trying to do I love it when you see those
in slow motion and it's like cat it's an art
the players that are competing for positions
they know where they stand they know who their
potential targets are internally it gets sorted
out by them their effort their commitment their
play we'll dictate who starts with our team oh wa
TS Rim bump back this side Mikey you can start uh
talking I'll start uh Hey juice want to switch at
any time uh yeah my nickname is uh juice There
You Go Juice hunt juice hunt my first year the
miners you know started playing well started
scoring a lot of goals in the playoffs and uh
they just thought thought I had the the juice on
the [Applause] I yeah it's I think it's pretty
cool nickname for all the juice Adrien Kee brought
onto the minor league ice as a firstr draft pick
once he reached the NHL in 2017 it took a while
to squeeze his talent to its full potential two
years ago was the first year where I really
thought that uh okay I'm going to have more of
a shooting mentality than I have previous years
I'm one timeing this thing oh heavy I think the
last two years he's just taken off to being at
the Star level in the NHL in the 2021 22 season
he more than doubled his previous career high
with 35 goals then last year he was an Allstar
for the first time the first king in 29 years
with a 40 goal season you know the last king
to score 40 goals was Luke Roby that's right yeah
every every time I look at him like oh man we got
to be patient with everyone now he's allowed our
organization to say let's be patient at times when
these kids are 20 21 years old because they're
they're going the right direction it just happens
at different times if I would have stay there
I would have scored a rebound yeah they still
believe in me as much as they do ever since
I got here you know it's been eight years now
and uh I love this city and love the team yeah it
has been cool we bought the place last year we're
been really happy here and uh yeah neighborhood is
awesome we're 5 minutes to the beach which is nice
5 minutes to the beach and then you see the whole
team all playing volleyball and then swimming and
we're all super close we love to host and have
everyone here it's yeah yeah I think La is also
perfect for you and your clothes and stuff I feel
like it's the biggest city really that has that
fashion access I mean a lot of different kind of
styles lot of uh regular day sneakers uh got some
golf shoes and stuff yeah and then here's for my
suits I usually wear for three games during ones
these are kind of one of my favorites uh never
actually wore these there's always a new pair
of shoes at the door new hat it's never ending
they wear this probably the most out of any suit
it's pretty dark green uh yeah it's have juice man
inside of it some skulls I feel like your Fashions
Chang CH so much too like even when we first
started dating I feel like it was very European
like that type style and then you slowly moved
into like La type but it's trendy yeah if kempe
is a reminder that young Talent can take time to
ripen there's hope that 22-year-old defenseman
Jordan Spence is ready to take the next step
in his own journey and make a real bid to seize
one of the team's few open roster spots he's an
NHL player without any doubt I think he's really
close to to to making our roster and we have to
make some decisions down the stretch based on a
number of different factors right now he's truly
in the mix and we're all cheering for [Music]
him I think the guys were itching to get on the
ice they know that regular season's comeing they
want to get their games in their reps in this
week come on Q come on C we're really gearing
up I think everyone's starting to jail right
now and um we're all excited to get the you
know get the games rolling you can't even
reach it you can't even reach it you can't
even reach it pl's personality seems to be one
that lends itself to become part of a team real
quick he's asking really good questions smart
questions he wants information that he believes
is going to help him you like watching video
and stuff or don't want I don't want to get
you thinking too much but your game when I
look at you I go there's another level here
you want to get there I think life in La now
is become uh comfortable for him yeah I like
I like that and I like uh like reminders
of good things because I tend to I tend
to concentrate on the negative like this what it
looks like when it's good no no I know that I'm
that way to sometimes we'll sit together but
I'm going to try to watch and help your game
roll your game and then but we just got to talk
that will help you yeah yeah thank [Applause]
you are we playing pool yeah yo you got to
break though he's too nervous to break on
camera I haven't played pool since we've
been here last so three years ago years
ago what is that two stripes no Trevor
Lewis and Drew dowy are happy to be back
on the same team even if they use their free
time to face off in some friendly competition
all right I'm going to put some down here
I think this guy thinks he's good these
are familiar surroundings and the walls tell the
stories of their greatest memories North End Bar
and Grill we used to come here all the time when
there wasn't very many people here and it's kind
of a little quiet spot for us to get away and you
know I think we ended up bringing the cup here a
couple times and then it seemed to get busier
and busier every time we came game and kind of
became a king's bar oh stay hot I'm like almost
undefeated on this table in life though in life
yeah yeah okay to be honest when we brought the
cup here I don't remember too much of what what
went on um but uh I know we had a great time
and got some good pictures and stuff like that
for the Memories this one's pretty cool we did
a parade down around here by the beach and it
was like so much fun party at my house tday just
the whole town how how much it was buzzing it was
pretty special feeling for sure then this one's
a blue pretty good one yeah that's my favorite
one I mean this picture I look like I've had
a few drinks here so it's great picture though
I've been coming here since as long as I've been
here and I think Drew used to live right there
too always was hanging out together away from the
rink and just kind of an easy fit to to go in and
live with him and Liv there for like 6 years or
something like that we' create games to play at
home and be chipping ping pong balls in the house
and just creating any kind of game we could there
a lot of pressure [Music] here yeah we had a lot
of fun and uh yeah it's just happy to be back
together oh I'm coming in hot I used to crush it
but I he ly I haven't played since I left here
like 3 years ago so he's lying they played
together for 12 years here then Lewis left
as a free agent in 2021 spending three seasons
away before reigning with LA this summer I was
obviously a weird time when I left playing here
my whole career and then um it was that kind of
that Co year the bubble year and actually was in
Winnipeg for that year and then been in Calgary
the past 2 years which I enjoyed my time there
but once I got the call from La this summer it's
kind of a no-brainer for me to come back told my
wife and she started crying and kids were happy
and obviously the first guy I text was this
guy I mean it's a lot of the same staff and
a lot of same management and stuff like that so
it's kind of uh easy coming to the rink and you
know it doesn't even feel like I left really
see you're not good sober pool he doesn't talk
smack to anyone but me pretty oh I don't talk
nearly as much as you either personally it was
uh super exciting to have him back one of
my best friends I think he's going to be
a big part to our team lovely back finish for
Trevor Lewis we were missing a player like him
I think a little bit in the last couple years and
someone who will do anything to the team play his
role and he's a really good professional so
he's going to help our young guys learn what
it's like to be a professional and what it
takes and overall it's just a great to time
[Applause] back we like won the cup
too quick in our careers and then it
seemed like it was easy and then you
realize how hard it is to be honest
we got to do it one more time it be it' be
hopefully this unal yeah got to do it one
more I believe we have a very good team
this year getting guys like Louis and
stuff like that kind of makes our team more
complete and we're just excited to get the
season started to see what we can do boom you
want another one one more I got to go get my
kids see you later see
you from crypto.com Arena tonight the LA Kings
host their cross town Rivals the Anaheim Ducks
the LA Kings have really added I think
a lot of depth to their lineup this is
a team that that's going to raise I think
a lot of eyebrows around the League this
season
okay for us we talked a lot about uh all parts
of our game one thing we haven't mentioned is
establishing it early and being direct if we're
chasing a two onone we're hunting Puck okay get
direct ear put pucks to pads come up with
it get that part of our game in uh right
off the bat starters all right back in we
got royy and Gabby uh up front we got Phil
Vic Mory and inette we got tals [Applause]
[Music] come on boys here we go here we go
boys come on come on hold on just a sec just
a sec we got a little something with Drew
first here we go come on with opening night
of the regular season now just a week away
games like tonight take on the form of true dress
rehearsals played at full speed with full Focus
he you guys are ready here du ready on the
Fly let's go black come on now let's go y
this young Anaheim defense is going to be
tested by this veteran La Club good two
men good two men keep it alive keep it alive
Harvey good job early early on your forehead
initial shot of the game comes from gabov next
play next Play Good Start Boys good Good Start
follow this up hunt hunt Go Get It Go Get
It copar gets it to the front of the net
and it's fired wide great chance for Quinton
Byfield I centered it and then you got a you
got a good wood on it actually it probably
just deflected right good job nice dubba
for the Kings head up keep going in on left
wing to F in to deep the r around chance hny
scores you guys are looking good great job good
job Mike I thought they were going to get it in
so I cheated that's why they got that shot fala
with his fifth 20 goal season a year ago as the
first goal of the night here shot Kings on Top
one nothing right here get up jua kept it in Kee
plays it down low now it's cented by harbertson
and a score great shot bomb Camp buried it with
a one-time two nothing la Dey good eyes deey good
eyes good eyes I had to one touch it though I had
to one touch it let's go tough ice now a shooting
ice got to Phil holes good heels good heels Point
save score on the rebound Carol grundstrom
bends home the rebound of gabov point shot
so the Kings now have a thre nothing lead that
I Carl way to be there the Los Angeles Kings
have been absolutely flying through the neutral
zone with period one tonight A you rat it's a
two hand come on [Applause] Dey physicality
picking up a little bit it looks like ducks
King yeah it's started to and now things getting
spicy between fiaa and Tristan luno and that'll
do it for the first period so a period dominated
by the Kings the Kings hope they get that in the
regular season okay just quickly we play we
play we play we're doing some good things in
the ozone using some of the things we talked
about we turn the puck over and our hunt and
our Gap is excellent there's no space in there
that allows us to get going and turn it back and
go the other way again so you're always ahead
keep that coming let's keep it going here see
if we can maintain momentum come [Applause]
on let me tell you a in a game like hockey
momentum can be a thorny element to maintain go
go go after all the results are dependent on so
many different factors oh my goodness the meld
of so many different individual performances on
the ice yeah let's go changing King's Fielding a
lineup that could look very much like an opening
night lineup but the finest teams the smartest
coaches and the best players are the ones that
work the hardest Work Work Work Care the most
don't let off the hook and consistently find ways
to perform a little better than they did the day
before without a doubt they came prepared to play
tonight a dedication to those truths is what
carves a path to the Stanley Cup and the idea
of momentum takes care of itself better
engine good job along the way excellent
the Kings win the game four to one good job
boys improved their preseason record to 51
and one talk to the group before the game
about structure the systems the execution
within them with all the other intangibles the
speed the pace that we did it the immeasurable
stuff that you just have to bring every night
and putting the two together and I thought we
did a good job of that there's a needle
that points us in the right direction now
for practice [Music] tomorrow next on behind
the glass seems a little more assertive and
confident like he wants that spot all these
guys want to play to gabov to fiala one
timer playing back in my hometown in Saw
Lake spotted my dad right away this is
your roughy Jersey it was a special special
night for more inside access to the Kings
training camp go to NHL network.com
or follow #b theeg glass on social
media